the las vegas raiders always looking for
that one guy because john gruden's the
head coach and they're going to have a
hard time protecting the one guy they
currently have and derek carr when tom
brady comes to town this is
the latest example of the nfl's revised
covet 19 protocol and again is this
something they should have been doing
from the start is this something that
they've developed on the fly in
consultation with leading
epidemiologists it doesn't matter
there's a new approach
you send trent brown one of the starting
offensive linemen home because he's
positive for covet 19. the next step is
you get everyone else who was in close
contact with him home as well just in
case for the raiders that means their
entire starting offensive line was sent
home on wednesday the first
serious day of practice in advance of a
game will they be back today
based on everything that's transpired
over the past few weeks i would be
surprised if they are
how do you get these guys ready to play
against a pretty damn good buccaneers
defense if you're doing everything from
home and you're not actually practicing
chris that that is that's going to be
some tough task now you know it's a
double whammy too you're coming off a
bye week i'm sure they've had a few days
off and these days of practice are
important because you kind of want to
get back in the swing of things
i don't know if the raiders had practice
on monday this week already to kind of
get things started sometimes that's what
happens during these bye weeks but
you know to your point mike
that damn this ain't the week you want
to have offensive line issues not with
this crew coming in there jpp and sue
and and barrett i mean they they got
they got some some dogs up front and i
mean like that in a respectful way to
where they're coming and that's the
great advantage and maybe one of the
great things the best thing in the whole
raiders roster is their o-line their
ability to run the ball you know teams
having to crowd the box because they can
be so overpowering and then we saw when
you do that with henry rugs in alignment
lineup and all that can lead to some big
plays down the field so
if they have a less than perfect o-line
against this group here there is no way
they're going to win this football game
i don't know where this is going to go
mike it's going to be interesting
i guess they were around trent is what
john gruden said yesterday do you think
yeah how happy am i i'm not happy i'm
concerned i'm really more concerned
about trent and his health than anything
this is coveted and i'm concerned about
anything or anyone that has it or is
near it and that that that that sounds
good and that's one thing about the
raiders they've said all the right
things this year gruden was out in front
of how we got to beat covet and this
than that and man they've had their fair
share of issues dating back to gruden
refusing to wear a mask when the league
requires him to wear a mask on the
sidelines
the
ridiculous incident from a few weeks ago
with all the players that went to the
darren waller charity event that was
held in an enclosed space with no one
wearing masks and way too many people so
i feel like they've been flirting with
something like this for a while and from
a strategic standpoint this is going to
potentially hurt them on sunday night
and from the nfl's perspective
oh well this is just one of the
potential inconveniences
that will arise from
the pandemic you're going to have guys
sent home and they're not worried about
the fact that guys aren't going to be
able to prepare for the game that's not
their issue their issue is
limiting the possibility of an outbreak
even if it means that the chances of one
team winning and one team losing are
going to be skewed that that's that's
success that's acceptable in the nfl's
eyes because what's not acceptable is an
outbreak that shuts down games no i mean
we know they're going to try to make
this happen and do all that hey yeah
yeah well you know when this thing's
arise you're right i first thing you
think of is with the raiders you just go
well i don't know who knows what they
were doing they're not in the trust tree
anymore after the charity event last you
know a few weeks ago
but this is going to have like extra
meaning i mean this is gruden versus
tampa bay the place he won the super
bowl
he is trust me charged up this week he
wants to win this game he wants to stick
it to tampa he wants to stick it to the
glaciers he's got respect for them but i
just know how this man works he wants to
win this football game so this will
drive him crazy and i think the other
thing too is you know again it just
shows you how fragile it is
and how teams and coaches still got to
do their best on a daily basis to
compete versus this virus
and
you know i i know some of it you can't
stop it and whatever else but you got to
continue to do your best and keep o lyme
o lyman separate in the meeting rooms
and all those type of things and
i just hope all those protocols will
were followed
and really for all the things that a
coach has to worry about you throw this
on top of it it just shows you that even
a guy like bill belichick can't ensure
completely that his key players will
stay away from it because cam newton got
it and that's what sent the patriots
season off the rails not having him for
three weeks throwing him back into the
fray on sunday against denver he wasn't
ready guys around him weren't ready and
it all begins with making sure that
players are available for maximum
practice time because your opponent
typically is and that is a huge
advantage the buccaneers are going to
practice all week the raiders aren't
going to have their offensive line for
practice all week probably going to show
on sunday night when the buccaneers
visit the raiders for the first time in
the new stadium in las vegas
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports